well good evening and welcome to
washington i'm shannon bream and tonight
for brett bear breaking tonight
this summit between president biden and
russian leader vladimir putin begins in
just hours
in geneva this will not be their first
meeting but this
is the time that joe biden is now
president and he's already sending
signals
about taking a tough approach with the
russians on a number of
issues white house correspondent peter
ducey starts us off tonight from
switzerland
good evening peter
shannon good evening president biden is
already here in geneva president putin
arrives
first thing in the morning we're told as
of right now the plan is not for the two
leaders to share a meal at any point but
there is some time built in for breaks
in this meeting that is expected to last
four or five
hours
with that biden leaves a friendly
meeting where the eu and u.s
settled a long-standing trade dispute
about planes involving airbus and boeing
i think the future is very very bright
and heads to switzerland for a sit down
with vladimir putin
i think putin has been testing this
president particularly with the cyber
attacks that we've seen
recently a senior administration
official outlines three of the topics
for the sit-down
ransomware attacks like those launched
from inside russia that recently
squeezed american meat and gas
supplies arms control as the u.s and
russia are
the world's biggest nuclear powers and
alexey navalny a putin political rival
in prison in russia navalny's death
would be another
indication that russia
has little or no intention abiding by
basic fundamental human rights
president biden also seems to think
putin can be a partner reigning in
other bad actors reining in nuclear
threats from iran and north korea
he mentions iran even though the
washington post reports moscow is
outfitting tehran
with a sophisticated spy satellite i'm
less concerned how joe biden stumbles
and bumbles his way through describing
vladimir putin that i am concerned about
how joe biden
behaves towards vladimir putin on
russian interference in american
elections
candidate biden claimed trump wasn't
tough enough on putin
he's putin's puppy once president biden
took it a step further
you know vladimir putin you think he's a
killer
i do that comment had putin calling for
a live
televised chat with biden who is now
trying flattery
instead a worthy adversary and tomorrow
begins a quest to have a better working
relationship with putin that began for
biden
10 years ago the very good news is the
president and i
agree 100 percent on the need to
continue to establish closer and closer
relationship
weeks ago there was uncertainty about
whether or not this meeting was going to
happen at all and a lot of will they
or won't they once it was announced the
president said he was going to come here
because
there was something that he wanted
vladimir putin to hear
and now that it's the eve of the meeting
white house officials are lowering
expectations a bit
saying they don't expect there to be a
big set of what they call
deliverables in this the first
one-on-one sit-down between
president biden and the leader of a
country that he once recently described
not as a competitor but as an opponent
shannon all right peter ducey live on
the road with the president
the world we'll be watching thanks peter
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else